DISCIPLINARY INVESTIGATION IS
UNDERWAY.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: JEFF, THANKS VERY
MUCH.
MICHAEL KNOWLES JOINS US NOW.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
I'M STRUCK BY THE STATEMENT BY
THE ONE WHO RUNS THE SCHOOL
SAYING THAT YOU ARE AGAINST
DIVERSITY, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE ARGUING FOR DIVERSITY,
THE DIVERSITY OF THE SEXES, WHAT
ARE YOU ARGUING?
>> THE LECTURER ITSELF IS
ARGUING FOR DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT
ON CAMPUSES.
CHANCELLOR AGARWAL IT IS A
DISGRACE TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
I WOKE UP THIS MORNING EXPECTING
AN APOLOGY FOR BEING ASSAULTED
DURING A LECTURE I WAS INVITED
TO GIVE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MISSOURI.
INSTEAD, I WAS SMEARED BASICALLY
AS A BIGOT, THEY REFERRED TO MY
CLAIM THAT MEN ARE NOT WOMEN AS
AN EXTREME VIEWPOINT AND THEY
TACITLY ARE PERMITTING POLITICAL
VIOLINS TO FESTER ON CAMPUS.
THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR BUT WHEN
THAT PERSON ASSAULTED ME, I
INITIALLY THOUGHT IT WAS PAINED,
I WAS TOLD BY MANY PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM IT WAS BLEACH, THEY LATER
DISCOVERED IT WAS A NONTOXIC
CHEMICAL THAT NEARLY LOOKED AND
SMELLED LIKE A TOXIC CHEMICAL.
THAT POINT IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WHAT MATTERS IS THE MESSAGE THEY
WERE SENDING.
THIS IS A WARNING SHOT TO
CONSERVATIVES ON COLLEGES AROUND
THE COUNTRY THAT IF YOU DO NOT
SHUT UP, IF YOU DO NOT COUNT OUT
TO LEFTIST ORTHODOXY, YOU WILL
BE BULLIED, YOU WILL BE SHOUTED
DOWN, YOU WILL BE PHYSICALLY
INTIMIDATED, AND MAY BE, NEXT
TIME, THAT SUBSTANCE WILL BE A
LITTLE MORE DANGEROUS.
A LITTLE MORE TOXIC.
IT IS FASCISM AS CLEAR AS
FASCISM CAN BE AND THE
UNIVERSITY ABANDON EVERY ONE OF
ITS CONSERVATIVE STUDENTS AND
ENCOURAGED THE AGITATORS AND
ENCOURAGE THE VIOLENCE.
SPIEGELMAN
>> Tucker: THIS IS A PUBLICLY
FUNDED UNIVERSITY THAT TAKES OUR
TAX DOLLARS AND WE SAY NOTHING
ABOUT IT AND WE SHOULD SHUT IT
DOWN IMMEDIATELY I WOULD SAY.
I WOULD ALSO ARGUE IT'S NOT JUST
CONSERVATIVE VIEWPOINTS BEER
THERE ARE MANY FEMINISTS WOULD
LIKE TO PRESERVE, ACKNOWLEDGMENT
OF THE BIOLOGICAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN FOR THEY
ARE APOLITICAL BIOLOGISTS WHO
TAKE IT TO A FACT OF WHAT YOU
SAID IS TRUE.
DID YOU SAY SOMETHING WE ARE NOT
AWARE OF?
>> THIS IS THE IRONY.
IF THEY LET ME GIVE MY LECTURE
LAST NIGHT, I WOULD MAKE THIS
VERY POINT THAT WHEN YOU SAY
THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
MEN AND WOMEN, A VERY
FASHIONABLE IDEA THAT'S COMING
TO THE PUBLIC CONSCIOUSNESS IN
THE LAST FIVE MINUTES, YOU ERASE
THE CATEGORY OF WOMEN.
YOU ARE A RACE THE CATEGORY OF
WOMEN'S EXPORTS.
YOU ERASE THESE CATEGORIES.
THEY ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
CIVILIZATION.
WHY DID THEY SCREAM, WHY DID
THEY SHOUT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, THE VERY FIRST
SENTENCE OF MY LECTURE, THEY
SHOUTED ME DOWN AND EVENTUALLY
THEY TRIED TO PHYSICALLY ASSAULT
ME?
IT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
ARGUMENT.
THEY HAVE NO WAY TO WIN IN A
BATTLE OF IDEAS, SO THEY ARE
GOING TO BULLY EVERY PERSON WHO
DOES NOT AGREE WITH THEIR
RIDICULOUS IDEOLOGICAL
FANTASIES.
AND WE NEED TO FIGHT BACK.
I WAS ASKED IF I'M GOING TO
CANCEL THE REST OF MY SPEAKING
TOUR?
THE COLLEGE SPEAKING TOUR JUST
GOT TEN CAMPUSES LONGER.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THEM
BULLY, WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET
THEM INTIMIDATE US, EVEN IF THE
UNIVERSITIES FAN EVERY OF THEIR
CONSERVATIVE STUDENTS.
SPIEGELMAN YOU ARE TAKING THE
GALILEO POSITION HERE.
YOU'RE ARGUING FOR SCIENCE IN
THE FACE OF A HYSTERICAL MOB
THAT WANTS TO HURT YOU FOR
SAYING IT.
>> I MAY HAVE GIVEN WHILE THE
LECTURE THAT THE SKY WAS BLUE
PRINT I'VE GIVEN MANY CAMPUS
SPEECHES.
I THOUGHT THIS ONE WOULD BE THE
MOST INNOCUOUS.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE THE
DRIEST.
IT'S A FACT PLAIN AS DAY.
IT'S A SCIENTIFIC FACT, IT'S A
SOCIAL FACT THAT MEN ARE
DIFFERENT FROM WOMEN.
ON THESE CAMPUSES, WHERE
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN TOTALLY
DISTURBED BY THEIR PARENTS,
RAISED WITHOUT ANY MANNERS AND
BY THE EDUCATORS WHO RAISE THEM
WITHOUT ANY EDUCATION, THEY NOW
WILL NOT TOLERATE ANY PLAIN
SPOKEN VIEWPOINTS, ALL THEY WILL
DO IS USE THE HECKLER'S VETO AND
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT,
THEY'LL BE VIOLENT AND
THREATENING YOU WITH SUBSTANCES,
THREATEN YOU WITH CHEMICALS,
THEY WILL SHUT YOU UP.
>> Tucker: WE SHOULD SHUT